[Musique]
ce qui caractérise l'aérotrain c'est la
sustentation sur coussin d'air
c'est à dire que le véhicule n'est pas
portée par des roues reposant sur des
rails mais qu'il aimait dg d'air qui le
font en quelque sorte flotter au dessus
de 100 rails l'aérotrain que nous voyons
ici à l'essai et le modèle pour longue
distance
il est propulsé par un réacteur et il a
déjà dépassé 400 kilomètres à l'heure
l'aérotrain qui devait assurer la
liaison série pantoise la défense
souhaite une vingtaine de kilomètres
devait lui être propulsée par un moteur
électrique linéaire plus propre et plus
silencieux mais la réalisation de ce
moteur a posé de nombreux problèmes
techniques
c'est ainsi que sa construction d'abord
confié à la firme merlin gerin avait
ensuite été confié à la firme jeu manche
naître après l'abandon de la ligne
cergy-pontoise la défense le problème se
pose de savoir si l'on va continuer à
développer cette technique mais pour
d'autres religions ou bien si on devra y
renoncer
[Musique]